Her low freak bitches and I attributed
it to cutting out refined sugars and
refined carbohydrates.
I think,
I think that stuff's poison,
but there's been studies showing it also
affects your brain and negative way as
well.
And people that eat refined sugar,
you know,
there's,
there's more brain atrophy.
I mean there's lots of correlations.
The one thing I will say is that,
you know,
there are people that are super physically
active and they're like working out
two hours a day and you know,
those guys,
they'll use refined sugar yeah.
To,
you know,
their,
their increased transport
glucose transporter in their
muscles and you're using
it as an anabolic way to
like get bigger muscle.
And I know guys who do that
after they work out the candy.
Yeah.
And,
and it,
it's not like it's,
it's,
you can't compare like people that aren't
working out like two hours a day or
two to normal people as
Freeman sedentary people,
weight lifters.
Yeah.
Weightlifters he pulled it are
just ripping their body apart.
There's a lot of savages out there that
are doing crazy power lifting workouts
and benching and squatting.
And I know a lot of guys who
like to eat candy afterwards.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's certainly,
you know,
I think that those people,
they're,
they're not,
it's not,
it's not acting the same way.
It's radically different requirement that
their body needs in terms of glucose.
And,
and the thing is,
I mean,
still,
it's like,
the way I think about it is
it's not really nutrient dense.
You know,
I like to like,
I'm like,
well,
there's lots of,
there's a reason.
Yeah,
there's a reason why I like to like
take and if you want the sugar and then,
you know,
I wouldn't get an orange or an
apple or something like that,
you should probably the
better move than eating candy.
But I think they just want a ton of it.
And what is the,
what's the anabolic factor?
Look,
if you were going to eat
candy or something like that,
has a bunch of refined sugar
after like an intense workout.
What would be the antibiotic factor?
Well,
the glucose,
so the,
the workout causes,
um,
Glucose transporters that transport
glucose to like go through the roof.
And so you start the glucose from your
bloodstream gets like sucked into the
muscle and then in the muscle,
you know,
you're,
you're basically,
you can,
you can use that as,
as,
as a way to,
to,
to have insulin and it can be anabolic,
right?
Where,
where,
whereas if you weren't doing that,
then the glucose in your bloodstream
and it can all sorts of small dense LDL
particles can start to form because the
inflammatory transformations that happen
and things like that.
Um,
that's at least my understanding
that's in combination of course with,
um,
I mean,
oh,
acids,
which are also important for the
growth of the protein and muscle.
But that's my understanding of it.
I think.
So like in general though,
if someone could cut one
thing out of their diet,
refined carbohydrates and refined
sugars would be a great way to go.
I think the one,
if you were to think about the one
easiest thing that you could do that would
have the biggest impact on your health,
and if we're talking,
if we're talking about,
we're not talking about someone who's
already Paleo or someone like you or I
were talking about like
standard American person.
Yes.
The one thing that they could do to have
the biggest impact on their health I
would say is to cut out refined sugar.
Like that's,
that's probably the biggest thing.
The easiest thing,
I mean I don't know how easy it is.
It,
you know,
it can be addicting.
Yeah.
And that's been shown dopamine levels,
you know,
can get activated.
Game B was basically proceeded from
the idea that what we live in is a game
theoretic landscape,
right.
That the winners in this game theoretic
landscape are individuals who have
figured out where there's a niche.
Some of them have figured out how to
engage in something called rent seeking,
which rent seeking basically means making
money without producing some without
producing value.
So there's a lot of stuff that goes on
in our economy that is not productive.
And good,
but nonetheless generates fortunes.
So that's rent seeking as opposed
to innovation or productivity.
You're talking about like
hedge fund type stuff,
moving money around.
Well,
I want to be a little careful about this
because it is quite possible for things
like hedge funds to actually
correct inefficiencies in
the economy in a way that
is productive.
That doesn't mean that that's
the average thing that,
so do things are you referring to?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
let's,
let's take the,
the ultimate example
that will make it clear.
A warlord is not responsible for,
um,
for building the road that they then
stand by the side of and extort money from
people who want to travel it.
A cable company may produce some benefit.
They obviously have infrastructure
that allows you to get content,
but what fraction of what you're paying
for is actually about them delivering a
service at some price and
making some reasonable profit.
And what fraction of it is about the fact
that they are an economic Goliath and
that you don't have enough choice to be
able to negotiate a decent price with
them?
So there's some fraction of what
they're producing that is productive,
but then there's a large amount of profit
there that isn't about productivity or
innovation.
It's about the fact that they own a
choke point and you can't get around it.
Um,
so we don't know what fraction of the
economy is a rent seeking and what
fraction of it is productive.
But there is,
especially if one is broad minded about
thinking about all the ways that one can
engage in rent seeking,
one can actually be destructive of value.
If you destroy future
wellbeing for our descendants,
it may look productive in the present,
but it isn't productive.
It's actually destructive.
So that's a kind of um,
rent seeking that we don't
even typically model.
But,
uh,
we're,
where are we headed?
So,
Oh yes.
So we live in a game theoretic
landscape that's both good and bad.
As you point out,
competition is a healthy
thing and competition in
markets produces a huge amount
of value.
So I hear people deriding capitalism and
I always want to make the same point to
them,
which is you've got two things glued
together and you are challenging them as a
package,
but there's no reason
they have to be packaged.
So we would be foolish to give up markets.
Markets are amazingly powerful
engines of innovation.
They are capable of solving problems
that we cannot solve deliberately,
even if we want it to.
So we need markets,
but we don't want markets ruling the
planet and deciding that anything that
spits out a profit is therefore good and
that we should be exposed to whatever
the market discovers can be a viable.
So what we want is ultimately to provide,
um,
provide incentive structures that cause
the market to produce things that are
good for us,
right?
In other words,
if you tell the market that you
want the solution to some problem,
the market can figure out how to solve
that problem and it will do it very well.
But if you allow the market to
decide what problems to solve,
it may end up,
for example,
addicting you to your phone,
right addicting to you.
To your phone in a way that
harms your social relationships,
harms your,
your parenting of your children,
harms all kinds of things
that are really important,
breaks the ability of your children to
have a educational experience in school.
We don't want the market discovering
how to disrupt useful functioning of
people.
We want the market to stay out of that
stuff and then to provide us benefits
that,
uh,
only it can provide,
like all of the mechanisms that now
allow us to navigate seamlessly in places
that we've never been avoiding traffic
that we wouldn't know to worry about.
Right?
Those are huge benefits and
they're capable of taking
a city that is to snarled
with traffic and reducing the degree
to which it is snarled with traffic.
So they're very powerful,
but we shouldn't,
we shouldn't throw the
baby out with the bath.
Water markets are good.
Allowing markets to
discover any and every,
uh,
mechanism for exploiting
you is not good at all.
And in fact,
it's a large part of why we're
in the predicament that we're in,
is that we let the market
decide what problems to solve.
Okay.